- So you,
you own a TexMex restaurant
and I've actually been
there, It's so good.
- Oh Good, I'm glad.
- It's called just Justin Queso's.
- I'm glad, Thank you.
- Do you?
- Oh My God.
Justin Queso's
I love a good pun name, That's fantastic.
- I wish I could take
credit for it, but I can't.
- I know. And you go in and
so like here it's awesome
for me because I'm Texan and
like anybody Texan coming
there's all this like
memorabilia, Willie Nelson.
It's all like, it's so cool.
And I really dig it.
- Oh, good, good.
- Yes. And the Queso's good.
How do you make it?
- Okay so, I'm, I'm a Louisiana boy.
So I kind of had to you know
you guys let me know how this is going.
Okay. They're all Texas.
That's like actually involved
behind the scenes besides myself.
- Yeah.
- But to me Queso's always good,
but I wasn't 'cause I
had, I hadn't been taught.
- Blasphemy.
- I hadn't been taught.
I hadn't been taught
and now I know what's good and what's not.
- Yeah.
- Thanks.
Thanks to this restaurant.
- Yours is good.
- Okay. Good, I love that.
- I loved it. I was so
I walked in there going,
"Okay, Justin"
- You're like
- Justin Queso's
I was like, I was like a
real Texan was walking in
TexMex. I'm like, this is be-
- on Sunset Boulevard.
Let's see how that works.
- I know, I was like could try Hollywood-
- and then I was like, it ate a VAT of it.
It was so good.
- Yes.
- I love that.
Wait, I love your Queso's so much.
I know you've had it, but I
didn't know if you'd had it.
So I bought it all for all of us
cause I really selfishly just wanted it.
- that's what was sitting there.
- I really just wanted it.
Thank you Justin.
- Alright, Okay.
- You've gotta try it.
- Thank you.
- Like, try it.
Oh, it's not runny.
It's been sitting,
waiting for me to shut up.
- Wait, it's been sitting
so usually it's runny.
- I'm still doing it.
- Better finish this off Justin Queso.
(laughing)
- When you go there, it's runnier.
I just wouldn't shut up.
So it like, you know?
- Well that's nice.
That's nice
- It's so good.